as the Foreign Affairs columnist for The
New York Times Thomas Friedman won the
2001 Pulitzer Prize for commentary next
mr. Friedman discusses his new book a
collection of newspaper columns about
September 11th and the aftermath it's an
hour and 15 minutes
hi everyone it's good to see everybody
welcome to everybody and especially to
Tom Friedman I'm Karla Koh and I'm
co-owner of politics and prose and I Tom
Friedman is our special friend
he has celebrated all of the the books
that he has published at politics and
prose and somehow when he is he comes
it's it marks a significant occasion in
our existence usually that we're
expanding and as you can see who we need
that again and when we expand I hope
that we'll have more chairs and even if
we everyone can't see at least there'll
be a way of more people being able to
sit down Tom Friedman has a special way
of making naughty world problems
understandable and immediate his humor
well we all remember his line six years
ago I think it was about Netanyahu he
said he is deeply deeply shallow
now and even more perilous times we have
a president who can be described that
way I've thought about that line very
very often this past year Tom Friedman
is our voice in the national dialogue he
stands for peace and moderation and
democratization you love his book has
collected column some predating the
horrible event of a year ago and most
written since or model of reason and his
journal which he kept traveling is
compelling
welcome again Tom Friedman Thank You
Carla it's it's a treat to be back here
I have fond memories of being in the old
store for Beirut to Jerusalem back here
for Alexis in the olive tree I didn't
think I'd be back quite so soon with
another book I was as some of you may
know I my publisher asked me after
Alexis if I would write a new book and I
told him yes I wanted to do a book on
golf and he said the Persian Gulf and I
said no that was not what I had in mind
but this certainly wasn't a book I had
in mind 13 months ago but it was the
book I felt I had to write and I'm glad
I did and I hope you enjoy it I thank
you all for coming out and I really
thank all of those who are standing I
know it's not comfortable I really
appreciate your being here and I hope
that I can make it an interesting
evening I'm going to talk for the next
20 minutes or so just to try to address
some of the most oft asked questions
I've gotten since 9/11 and questions
normally that have come from people but
that I've asked myself and hopefully use
those as a trigger to lead off a
discussion I think the most most off gas
question
that I've asked myself since 9/11 is who
were those guys who were those 19
hijackers who aborted those planes
almost a year ago now and flew them into
the World Trade Center the Pentagon in a
field in Pennsylvania and I've asked
myself that question not only out of
curiosity but out of anger and out of a
desire or a feeling that if we don't
know who these people were
if we don't understand fully what
motivated them we can't begin to really
tackle this problem and so that's been a
theme that I've really been on from the
very beginning now what I basically
concluded is that the hijackers these 19
guys fall into two categories one
category I call the Saudis and the other
category I call the Europeans there are
really two distinct categories there and
let me explain to you what I mean by the
two the Saudis were what I would call
the muscle guys the guys who were in the
back of the plane who his job was to
restrain the passengers guys who were
really not instrumental to the plot and
were only brought in according to a bin
Laden himself at the last minute without
really knowing much other than that they
were involved in a martyrdom operation
as he said I call them the Saudis
because virtually all of them came from
Saudi Arabia from Saudi Arabia's hacia
province which is in the southwest
corner just north of Yemen in fact most
of them came from they all lived on
roughly the same highway down there and
they are part of a group of a young
generation of Saudi males that I would
call the sitting around guys because
there's there are a lot of young men
there sitting around these young men
were came from middle to upper-middle
class families in many cases they were
the first to be educated through high
school or college they a lot of them
initially sort of entered the fold of of
al-qaeda
by being recruited for the war in
Afghanistan against the Soviet Union
when that war was over they came back to
Saudi Arabia it seems that there was
more sitting around more going to
radical mosque where they were exposed
to radical preachers and somewhere along
the way they were in Osama bin Laden's
rolodex and when the time came for the
operation
they were tapped on the shoulder and
recruited and they came what produced
them the the kind of engine that
produced them is what I call the wheel
of bin Laden ISM and the wheel of bin
Laden ISM is made of three basic parts
the first part is autocratic
anti-democratic authoritarian regimes
which really predominate today in the
Arab Muslim world we had an Arab League
summit a couple months ago 22 nations
represented not a single one represented
by a leader elected in a free and fair
election there is no region in the world
where you could have a regional summit
and not a single leader there was
elected in a free and fair election not
sub-saharan Africa not Latin America not
anywhere and this unfortunately is
really the dominant political mode in
that space for Morocco to the border of
India so the top of the wheel are these
anti-democratic authoritarian regimes in
order to gain legitimacy these regimes
in the absence of elections basically
empower or strike a bargain with what I
would call anti-modernist religious
leaders and educators and it's a very
simple transaction the anti-modernist
religious leaders and educators bless
the regime as it were and the regime
blesses them with the imprimatur of the
government as the official spiritual
leaders and provides them with cash to
operate
well these anti-modernist religious
leaders in turn dominate an education
system which produces young people who
in many cases are not prepared
basically to deal with the modern world
that produces poverty and the wheel
really just goes around in a
the anti-democratic regime has
reinforced the anti-modernist religious
educators the anti-modernist religious
educators reinforce the anti-modernist
religious education the anti-modernist
education produces young people
unprepared for modernity that produces
poverty it reinforces the autocracy and
the wheel just goes around and around
and it spins off thousands upon
thousands of sitting around guys who
really aren't prepared for the modern
world and are prey to radical preachers
who tell them that all the problems in
the world come from America
that's the Saudi guys that's the rough
profile I would draw of them the really
interesting characters though I would
argue are what I call the Europeans now
the Europeans are Muhammad Atta and the
key pilots and plotters the guy who's
who really drove the plot the Hamburg
cell the guys who were studying at the
harburg Hamburg Technical College and
were part of that cell there what you
notice if you look at the biographies of
these guys and if you look in fact at
the biographies of every other one of
the terrorists who have been exposed
since 9/11 something jumps out at you
and what jumps what jumped out at me is
the fact that not a single one of them
left home left Egypt or Saudi Arabia or
Morocco or Tunisia not a single one of
them left home a Muslim radical every
one of them was converted to radical
Islam in Europe in their encounter with
the West and it is there where the spark
the cognitive dissonance cognitive
dissonance excuse me for their
radicalism was really struck as I say
not only true of the 9/11 hijackers mr.
Shah the Pakistani who murdered Danny
Pearl converted in England Moussaoui the
gentleman who went out to Minnesota to
try to learn how to fly a 747 but wasn't
interested in learning how to
and converted he's the Tunisian son of
Tunisian mother converted to radical
Islam in France mr. Reid the bozo
couldn't blow up his own tennis shoes
converted to radical Islam in a British
prison the two guys who assassinated
Shah Massoud two Tunisians converted to
radical Islam in Belgium every one of
these guys was converted to radical
Islam in their encounter with Europe now
what's all that about I think a lot of
factors go into it the first is the fact
that Europe is not a melting pot people
can criticize America for not being a
good melting pot or a warm enough
melting pot but I think we do a pretty
good job a Europe does not aspire to be
a melting pot and these young men come
to these European countries and they
find themselves really alienated and
often shoved out and drifting to the
edges of society they gather together as
this group did at Hamburg University
into prayer groups for warmth and
solidarity which is perfectly
understandable some then gravitate to
more radical prayer groups and some
gravitate to still more radical prayer
groups what also fuels them is the fact
that Egypt Saudi Arabia a lot of these
countries have evicted their most
intense Muslim radical preachers to
Europe where they have found a refuge
and been given political refuge by
governments there under the guise of
being accorded political asylum so you
have there both the raw material of
alienated young men and you have the
preachers but there is I think a larger
story here and I try to frame it in the
book in computer terms because I think
it really gets to the core of the
cognitive dissonance that really
afflicted these young men as people have
read Alexis in the olive tree know I
tend to like to put things in computer
terms so I'm going to put this in
computer terms Islam's self-identity and
I mean no insult and no insult should be
from this but Islam self-identity is
that it is the most complete an ideal
version of monotheism if sees Muhammad
the Prophet Muhammad as the seal of the
prophets
and it sees Islam as the completion of
the monotheistic Creed which was begun
with Judaism through Christianity but
completed in its fullest and most ideal
form in the Quran it sees itself I would
argue as God 3.0 and these young men are
raised in a world where they are
nurtured on the idea that Islam is God
3.0 it sees Christianity as God 2.0 and
it sees Judaism as God 1.0 now the
cognitive dissonance happens and the
reason happens in Europe is because
these young men coming to Europe imbued
with and raised on the notion of Islam
is God 3.0 and they discover and have to
face the reality that got 2.0 and God
1.0 are living so much more prosperously
so much more powerfully so much more
democratically than God 3.0 and that's
really where the spark happens because
somebody has to explain that and the
person who explained it was Osama bin
Laden and people like him and the way
they explained it was very simple they
explained it in two ways one was that
God 1.0 and God 2.0 got together and did
something to God 3.0 got together and
took something away from God 3.0 that
was one explanation another explanation
is that the leaders who should be
directing God 3.0 have drifted away from
the authentic version and corrupted and
corroded it those are the explanations
of course there is another explanation
and the other explanation is that god
2.0 isn't really got 2.0 it's actually
got 2.0 point 1
it's the reformed and enlightened
version it's Christianity that's gone
through the laundromat of the
Enlightenment and Reformation separating
church from state and interpreting its
faith
a way that can embrace modernity and God
1.0 is not really God one fly no it's
actually today got one point 0.1 it's a
Judaism that's gone through the
Enlightenment and Reformation separating
synagogue from state and reinterpreting
its faith for many Jews to embrace
modernity until there is a God 3.0 point
1 there's going to be a problem until
there is an Islam that has been
interpreted in terms of its own text and
by his own faith adherents and by his
own spiritual leaders in a way that can
separate mosque from state and embrace
modernity this cognitive dissonance is
going to be there and so to me that's
really where the spark of 9/11 comes
from and why all of these radicals were
minted not at home but in the middle of
the West now the conditions the second
question might then be you know what are
the conditions under which one could
imagine a god 3.2.1 being articulated
and and here we get to the issue of why
I have been such a strong advocate of
democracy and democratization in the
Arab and Muslim world all over the world
for that matter and it's because you a
lot of people will say to me geez Islam
is a really angry religion to which I
say no I don't think that's true but I
think there are a lot of Muslims who are
angry I think that's what's true and I
think a lot of Muslims are angry because
they live in countries where they have
no voice in their government have no
voice in their future they live under
corrupt dictatorial regimes it's a very
interesting thing you know that I've
learned myself and my travels it's a
very simple thing but context matters
the context within which people live
their life really matters and what is
religion but a mirror on the context of
your life you know what's the second
largest Muslim country in the world you
know trick question most people don't
get it it's called India Oh
okay India which has a hundred and fifty
million Muslims obviously I've been
roughly a million Hindus but has the
second largest Muslim population in the
world and Indian Muslims have issues
they have economic grievances there have
been occasional outbursts as we saw in
Gujarat earlier this year attacking
Indian Muslims by Hindu nationalists
they have political issues of
discrimination but I asked myself why
wasn't there a single Indian Muslim in
al-qaeda does it have to do with the
fact maybe that the President of India
today is a Muslim does it have to do
with the fact that the richest man in
India today is a Muslim software
engineer the founder of Infosys does it
have to do with the fact that the
context within which Indian Muslims live
and plan their lives and achieve their
goals is a democratic context that is
basically open to them context really
matters and the reason it's related to
this religious question is I was just in
India a few weeks ago you know there's
only one mosque I know of in the world
where Muslim women have demanded the
right to pray alongside men in the
mosque which isn't allowed the you know
where that was it was in Hyderabad India
and you know why that was because women
in a democratic context feel empowered
and protected to raise these issues here
in the first week of the war of
Afghanistan one of the Muslim leaders in
India called on Indian Muslims to join
the jihad against the United States and
one of the most popular film stars in
India is an Indian Muslim woman I forgot
her name right now maybe someone here
knows and she in a debate carried live
on Indian TV told this guy basically you
want to fight in Afghanistan you go you
go okay but I'm not going and we
shouldn't go because this isn't our
fight I mean that's what you get in a
democratic context women feel empowered
to raise these issues but not only when
people who want to raise these
theological questions are protected and
empowered to do that the Reformation
happened when princes in Germany were
ready to protect the Reformers Martin
Luther and his like from the papacy if
you don't create the political space for
a Reformation it's not going to happen
so democracy is really important now the
next question I often get from people is
um oh yeah freedom you know but if you
have democracy in Saudi Arabia
do you realize what will happen they
will be spewing out hate against America
in their press and from their mosques
and they will teach hate against
infidels in their schools and they will
spawn terrorism to which I say good
morning Mary sunshine what do we have
now okay
what do we have now but just that we
have a factory for that I want the
Islamists to get elected in Saudi Arabia
I want them to be responsible and I want
them to have to be responsible for their
own radicalism in front of their own
people I want them to have to look their
people in the eye and say folks we're
not gonna sell any oil anymore to the
infidels because they're bad now that
doesn't mean there'll be no Disney World
this year and there'll be no University
of Texas and there'll be no trip to the
United States and there'll be no trip to
Lebanon and your income is going to be
cut in half I want them to have to be
responsible for their own radicalism in
front of their own people because only
then will you get the war within the war
of ideas within by them we can raise the
questions but only they can answer them
and the way place where that war is now
going on the Muslim country the only
Muslim country where people
spontaneously went into the streets on a
candlelight vigil in the week after
September 11th was Iran okay and that is
not an accident because Iranian said
enough democracy now - no they want more
of it and they've had enough Islam
crammed down their throat by crackpot
mullahs - no they want less of it and
what is going on today in Iran is a
terrific experiment and struggle of
Iranians trying to find
balance between Islam and democracy and
god bless them because if they can find
that balance if they can find that
balance the impact it's going to have on
the whole Muslim world will be a hundred
times greater than the Iranian
Revolution ever was and we should be
careful as we think about Iraq because
if you follow what happened in Iran last
week something very important president
hot to me reflecting this I was just in
Iran two months ago
reflecting this feeling from the people
basically told the conservative
hardliners there who are keeping
everyone down I'm mad as hell and I'm
not going to take it anymore and we have
to be careful that if we go into Iraq
now the Conservatives and hardliners
there don't use that as an excuse to
abort this whole process because what's
going on in Iran today is tremendously
important we cannot move it along any
faster there's nothing we can do it has
to go at its own space and its own pace
in its own way
we can raise the questions but only they
can answer them and they're only going
to be answered in a democratic context
so those are a few of the questions that
early questions I had another question I
often get obviously is what do we do
what can we do in terms of simply
confronting these sort of issues and
dumb here I'd say we have to do two
things um one is we have to kill Osama
bin Laden I know that sounds you know
sometimes politically incorrect and
whatnot because people often say
violence doesn't solve anything and
actually that's not true okay because
you know violence you know that is
indiscriminate and violence that is
misdirected and violence that is
feckless doesn't solve anything but
violence said is directed against people
want to kill you for who you are not
what you do solves a lot okay and we
should have no illusions about that all
right we need to send two very important
messages one is that you send 3,000 you
send 19 young men over here to kill
3,000 of our people we will track you
down if we have to look in every cave in
Tora Bora to find you okay because
justice will be served that deterrent
message has to go forward
you cannot come over here to our country
and do that and they'll go back home and
sip Turkish coffee and make videos
chortling about it
we will track you down that is important
and the second reason the second reason
it's important okay is that these
particular terrorists bin Laden and his
crew they were they were in my view the
Michael Jordan and Chicago Bulls of
terrorism okay they were really a unique
and a uniquely dangerous group bin Laden
combined two things which I've never
seen before in a terrorist he was a
combination of Charles Manson and Jack
Welch very unusual okay very unusual um
the most mendacious and evil sort of
mine combined with the corporate and
organizational skills of a fortune 500
manager guys like him don't come along
every day
okay and what has been accomplished by
either driving these guys underground
and paralyzing them or hopefully having
eliminated them is that we have bought a
lot of time here and the last year is
evidence of that we have defeated we've
wiped out Michael Jordan and the Chicago
Bulls now now we're dealing with the
bench and the CBA okay and that's what
we're dealing with with mr. Reid a guy
who couldn't figure out how to light his
own tennis shoes showed up for a flight
with no luggage having not shaved in six
days and saying I'd like a one-way
ticket to America that's what you get
when you go down just one rung okay
there's a big gap between these guys now
the thing you have to understand about
Al Qaeda I believe is that if you want
to understand al Qaeda don't think IBM
don't think flow chart with headquarters
here and you know all this stuff out
there think McDonald's okay think
franchises this is a franchise operation
we have wiped out the central
headquarters we've wiped out
Ray Kroc and the corporate headquarters
in San Diego but there are still a lot
of franchises operating out there but
none of them have quite the skill the
resources audacity and imagination yet
that bin Laden and his crew had so I
think it's very important to take these
people on it's more important to kill
their ideas much more important at the
end of the day that's really what will
make us safe and that's to take on their
ideas now there are things that we can
do to make that easier and I think we
should be doing everything we can do to
create an international environment
where the regime's in which these people
reside in our Ray's are ready to take on
their ideas I think we should be as
energetic as we possibly can in trying
to bring a peaceful resolution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict much more
energetic than this regime has been I
think we have to stop telling the world
either you're with us or against us in
the war on terrorism but in the war
against global warming and making this a
greener planet well sorry
we've got better things to do we'd like
to consume as much energy as we please
thank you very much if we're going to
have the world with us in a war on
terrorism where we stomp around from
Manila to Afghanistan to Manhattan we
have to be the best global citizens we
can be and we're not gonna have allies
in this video so we have to do thank you
we have to do everything we can to
create an environment in which people
will want to take on these ideas and
where we will take away excuses from
them for not taking on these ideas but
at the end of the day they have to take
on the bin Laden ISM and here there's
been just an enormous failure since 9/11
because the thing you have to understand
about bin Laden is that he's an
authentic character as hateful you know
as I think years as a person bin Laden
is an authentic character all right he
came from one the richest non-royal
family in Saudi Arabia he gave up the
life of a multi-millionaire in Saudi
Arabia to go off to Afghanistan and live
in a cave and fight the Soviet Union
and help drive it out of Afghanistan
unfortunately he got twisted after that
and turned his energy against the United
States but he's an authentic character
and you only defeat that kind of
authenticity with another authenticity
bin Laden articulated an authentic Arab
Islamic retrograde vision and it can
only be defeated with an authentic
Islamic progressive vision and that's
what totally has not happened since 9/11
the pattern of these regimes basically
is to expel their Islamists to export
them to the West or put them in jail but
it's never to take on their ideas and
the reason they don't articulate a Arab
authentic progressive message is because
very few of them are authentic Islam ik
progressives none of the leaders in
these countries really are or very few
of them are what they do instead is
expel their Islamists and then because
they feel guilty about that and exposed
by that they then empower those left
behind who are just slightly less
violent in many cases and whose ideas
only differ from bin Laden's by degree
until and unless they take on their
ideas and empower others to do so we're
never going to be able to confront bin
Laden ISM talk I have my water
now let me just finish with a couple of
points um people have asked me um what's
the column you got the most feedback on
I should say positive feedback negative
feedback would be hard to decide but
positive feedback since 9/11 and it's
very clear to me which columns and it
relates to something I said earlier I
did two columns basically one was called
let's roll and the other is was called
ask not what
and they basically challenged President
Bush to call in the American people
after 9/11 to do something hard I mean
the message from the administration was
were in a war go shopping we're in a war
let's party
we're in a war let's cut taxes we're in
a war consume as much energy as you want
ever since 9/11 it has been my view that
President Bush has used all the
incredible energy of the American people
as demonstrated by the willingness to
contribute a billion dollars in a month
basically to the victims the tremendous
energy of people to want to participate
in some way in this war by contributing
to a project of American renewal and
American safety and there is no project
I think would be greater than that than
a project for energy independence and
conservation a project they would have
called on people to turn down their
thermostats a little bit or do what my
wife and I did which was gone and buy a
Prius okay which gets 50 miles to the
gallon or have every school in America
buy a solar light bulb for a school in
the developing world that would be sent
to them with the decal of the United
States of America on it so as these kids
grew up they would remember who lit up
their nights I could stand here all
night and think of ideas and we got none
and I believe that was a huge wasted
opportunity I believe President Bush has
basically used the energy of September
11th to take a hard right agenda from
September 10th and drive it into a
September 12th world okay and I think
with a real loss opportunity for the
country um this is administration that
has never given a sister souljah speech
it has never asked its people or anybody
else to do anything hard and I believe
is squandered a tremendous moment and
judging from the reaction I've gotten
from readers I think there's a lot of
Americans who feel that as well let me
close with just one point on the issue
of globalization I wrote a book on
globalization and one of the issues
that's been interesting for me and
people have asked me a lot about how
have your views changed since 9/11 and
you know the the most interesting thing
that really has struck me in my travels
on this question is um I guess what I've
learned most what is I found most
disturbing is that what I've seen in my
travels is how we have become connected
technologically to one another so far
ahead of our ability to actually
understand one another and so we've
wired the world we all now hear each
other we can see each other often yet
the frameworks to actually understand
what we're hearing lag far far behind I
I first started thinking about this on a
trip to Indonesia I was meeting with a
group of Indonesian journalists and
there was a young woman there from the
Far East economic review who suddenly
just went off on a Jag on Bill O'Reilly
and of the Fox channel and how much he
detested Bill O'Reilly and I I said to
her well when you're in America don't
don't watch Bill O'Reilly she said no no
Oh Riley's now in my Jakarta cable
package okay
um Bill O'Reilly in the Fox channels in
her Jakarta cable package and so she has
to listen to his views on Islam and if
she could communicate by email she'd
probably send him her views on Islam and
believe me they would be like ships
passing in the night
so all this wiring of the world instead
of bringing about greater understanding
is actually been lifting the world's
blood pressure we kind of hear it's like
read a dinner conversation now
everybody's shouting at everybody else
and you can't get up from the table you
know um and you know you got to hear
everything and what's dangerous about it
and this has been particularly clear to
me is um the way in which the Internet
has become an instrument for passing on
and disseminating some of the most vile
rumors since 9/11 most importantly the
complete lie that 4,000 Jews were warned
not to go to work on the morning of
September 11th that was basically
disseminated on the Internet
and you know what people don't
understand is that the Internet is an
open sewer of untreated unfiltered
information it can make you smarter
faster than any technology I know and it
can make you dumber faster than any
technology I know but unfortunately
people often especially young people
can't discriminate between the two and
people have often said to me but but but
I read it on the Internet as if that
patina of technology somehow can
overcome the fact that it's just an
electronic version of the National
Inquirer in some cases and that problem
I don't know how to heal that problem
but that is a problem and I bumped up
against it in a lot of quarters of the
world let me just say in in conclusion
that dumb on that same trip actually to
Indonesia I ran into an American
diplomat who told me that she had been
to Milan in East Java and saw a young
boy there riding a bike and he was
wearing an Osama bin Laden t-shirt and a
New York Yankees baseball cap
okay and I didn't see it but I can
believe it because I've seen those kinds
of things in a lot of places around the
world and in a way that young boys
uniform it really captures where a lot
of young people are around the world
today there's an enormous attraction and
pull and envy and appeal visa vie
America and there's a certain revulsion
and also a desire to retain and concern
about one's own olive tree one owns
authenticity one's own roots there's a
tension between that young boy and and
despite what they say they're really
open they can go either way
but it's clear to me what our challenge
is in this year after 9/11 and it's to
make sure he grows into the cap not the
t-shirt thank you very much
questions we please stand up when you
ask your question and if you're not
standing up already and Tom Friedman
will repeat the questions the two arab
leaders that made peace with Israel were
themselves autocrats it's hard to
imagine put to the road in either of
those two countries today
on the other hand one democracy it was
not clear to me that in a democratic
setup that they well the president yeah
that Israel would wouldn't vote for
peace that's not because it's not a
democracy I'd bet because of the
political that's because of the context
yeah exactly
did y'all hear the question he wants to
know if I'm gonna stay in sign books
afterwards and um absolutely and bless
you for asking no the question was the
two Arab leaders who have made peace
with Israel the King Hussein of Jordan
and Anwar Sadat of Egypt weren't
Democrats but I'm not sure that and so
therefore if you had democracy in these
countries you wouldn't have had peace
but that that's roughly the question but
to you I'd ask question how do you know
since who is to say that a
democratically elected government in
those countries wouldn't have made peace
with Israel I don't think that that is
necessarily obvious because maybe one
reason for the rage and hatred that
still boils up in those countries like
Egypt you know which led to Sadat's
death is is because it's not a democracy
so I don't think it's self-evident that
just because the ones who did it were
dictators Democrats could never do it
just the opposite I'd feel a lot more
comfortable if these pieces were made by
Democrats and not by dictators could
state and could make peace against the
yeah there's no question that's the case
I think the more you know problematic
question the one I'm wrestling with is
how do you get from here to there you
know okay you've got the regimes that
you've got how do you get from from
those to something resembling a
democracy because that's a long process
I think that's one of the most important
questions in political science today
what is democratization and how do you
do it and every country is really
different but I do think it's some what
we have to keep in mind is real
democracy isn't about voting it's about
all the other stuff
it's about rule of law it's about
constitutionalism
it's about regulatory agencies and
oversight it's all about the rights of
minorities not about you know majority
rule and it's really they got to be a
gradual process I look to Thailand and
Turkey as as interesting examples of how
you do it basically we're an
authoritarian regime gradually seeds
power starting with local elections
regional elections of freer press in
franchising
women you know basically gradually
gradually seeding power but leaving in
reserve or holding in reserve a certain
power in the event that people as they
gain power try to use it in some
anti-democratic way this is a 50 60 year
transition and so it's gonna take a long
time but you know the first rule of
holes is when you're in one stop digging
and you know right now we just want to
get people to stop digging and start
thinking about some other things now you
know one of the important things about
post 9/11 is that we've been raising
these issues and what I found in
traveling through the urban Muslim world
is that if you ignore the press and if
you ignore the sort of the phony
intellectuals and you actually talk to
real people they're talking about all
these issues around their dinner tables
there's a real conversation going on I
don't know where it's gonna go I don't
know how long it's gonna last I don't
know who will lead it and I don't know
how far it can go without more democracy
but I tell you people are talking about
these issues Bahrain is going to have is
moving to become a constitutional
monarchy the smallest you know country
there
but and others experimenting morocco is
experimenting these are they'll be
flawed there'll be two steps forward one
step back but at least you see some
people now understanding where they
they've got to go and starting to at
least experiment in that direction so I
don't think all is lost we go back over
here and we'll come back yeah I feel I
live in a dictatorship right now I mean
I and I'm really frightened that we're
I'm really frightened that we're being
if you think that's true and secondly
you keep talking about we should meaning
the nation but the nation doesn't what
do people do probably react yeah that's
it the lady asked she feels that she's
not living in a democracy herself that
the countries being um kind of
willy-nilly dragged into a war that no
one's voted on and while one can talk
about we should do this and we should do
that it's not happening we don't have a
president right now who reflects that
and you know those are those are serious
issues but I I'm not going to dodge your
question but let me sort of come at it
from from just like today's paper I mean
your friend of mine said to me last
night my friend does Steve Cohen who's
one of my sort of gurus he said you know
the bush people are to foreign policy
what Gingrich and his crowd were to
domestic policy okay and I call it the
contract without the world okay or or
the contract only with America and I
think that's where they're sort of gut
impulse starts you know now when we talk
about Iraq my my and I won't pull my
punches here at all I lean in favor of
doing something in Iraq I lean in favor
but only if we can do it right because I
do believe Saddam Hussein is a really
bad guy who is doing really has done
really bad things and will continue to
do them so that's frankly where I come
from but I'm only going to support it
when I hear the case and when I see how
it's made
now these guys have done this
completely ass-backwards they leak their
military plans before the justification
for the war so we had the whole world up
in arms um but and then they allowed
other people because they did it that
way to define what their aspirin for
them it's really a wag the dog it's
about the November elections
it was completely loopy the way the way
they did it and um you know why they did
it that way I don't know as as you might
realize I'm not exactly tight with this
administration okay so they don't
confide in me I don't confide in them
and so I don't know why they did it that
way but I think they're paying a huge
price for it now but what struck me I
just got around to reading the post
today I'm on my way here and the front
page is all about you know Bush had to
meet in the White House with the
congressional leaders and basically say
to them I'm gonna listen to you and yeah
it's way too late you can say all of
those things but the fact is the
democracy worked at the end of the day
he's doing nothing at the end of the day
if the public and the Congress is
against it I really believe that and I
think it's very important for them to
understand there's a Norma's hubris
among a certain core of this routine
I'll go I said this is not Bush - this
is Reagan three okay this is Reagan
cubed this is the undiluted essence and
coffee grinds of the Reagan
administration okay this is the real
core okay these guys and and there's a
lot of hubris that came with that and
and you really saw you see see we have
the power today to destroy the Taliban
regime in Afghanistan on our own and we
did it on our own without NATO we have
the power today to destroy Saddam
Hussein's regime in Baghdad on our own
but you know we don't have the power for
it to rebuild Afghanistan on her own to
rebuild Iraq on her own and that gets to
sort of my issues you know I can see and
accept the moral and strategic argument
for taking on Saddam Hussein but I have
several questions I first of all want it
to be debated and approved by the
Congress because this would be I have a
kind of a Pottery Barn view of foreign
policy when it comes to these things you
know you're going to the Pottery Barn
the sign says break it
and you own it okay well if we break
Iraq we oniy Rock if we break
Afghanistan we own Afghanistan
those are big problems to own and if
we're gonna take that on and there are
in fact legitimate moral and strategic
arguments for doing it
we need to do it with everybody holding
hands and stepping forward together
because this is a big project and the
attempted assassination of Hamid Karzai
today and the fact that his killers had
to be deterred by who his American
security guards killed his would-be
assassins do you realize the subtle
message that sins that you are now being
protected you know by the Americans and
how they can D legitimize him I truly
worry about him so these are really
complicated problems there are real
issues at stake and if we're gonna take
it on number one we need to do it
together number two it seems to me if
we're gonna take it on there has got to
be a causes Bela there's got to be a
trigger that we cannot just go at a key
rock from a standing start we got to go
back to the UN offer resolution very
clear very simple unadorned full and
complete inspections anytime anywhere in
accordance with all the 19 previous UN
resolutions on this do you agree or do
you disagree we have to show as Bush one
did that we will go the extra mile to
find a diplomatic solution because
without that we won't have the allies we
need thirdly we need a war plan that can
work I'm not an expert in that I would
leave that to the experts but I as I
just imagine it I don't know quite how
you do this how you take apart a country
not in the middle of a war not after a
war but from a kind of standing start
this isn't Germany and Japan after World
War two it's not Bosnia and Kosovo in
the throes of a civil war with
everything destroyed and you come in the
middle of it so we need a plan that our
military has confidence can actually do
the job I don't put those out there as
obstacles and when you reach those three
you know when you overcome those three
I'll give you three more
those to me are the serious issues that
we have to debate and the N raised and
we got to approach this problem with
humility okay because I don't know very
much about Iraq and I don't know anyone
who does okay and this is a really
complicated country and what I resent is
people who simply say you haven't signed
up yet
you're an appeaser you're you know
whatever I'm sorry that is that is
really I think truly unbecoming
unhelpful and that's what will drive a
lot of Americans away from this so I
think of the president can make the case
and does make the case and goes through
the exercise of making the case because
if you can't do that for yourself in
your own people then there's usually a
problem you know and so that's really
what I'm waiting for myself to decide
what you know what I what I think about
it I don't I don't they don't know I
really I think it's a such a serious
question that I don't want to just
freelance on it I don't I don't know
when you go back over here yeah
be around the region yeah well what
would be the repercussions around the
region if we were effective in doing
this and it's a really interesting and
important question let's start with you
know the central repercussions because
that um and I'm it might surprise you to
me it's what happens to the price of oil
okay because Iraq today has the capacity
to pump five million barrels of oil a
day it's only pumping a very small
amount of that has it can now do up to
two but it's even doing less than that
now if we got a different regime in Iraq
that then opened the country up to
fuller exploration and the repair of its
oil fields and Iraq went up to five
million barrels a day
well that would lessen our dependence on
Saudi Arabia it would also affect the
oil price now to me oil is the heroine
in this whole story
because it's our addiction to that oil
which prevents us from telling the truth
to these regime we talk about our
special relationship with Saudi we don't
have a special we have a special deal
with Saudi Arabia and the deal is a
dollar twenty nine gas and we keep the
bad guys off your doorstep that's the
relationship we have with them okay you
know I've never met an addict who told
the truth to his pusher okay and we have
not been telling the truth you know to
these people because of our addiction to
oil now their addiction total their
access to oil is what allows these
anti-democratic regimes to enslave their
women basically prevent them from being
part of the workforce and achieving
their full aspirations and to stay in
power you take away the oil and what
happens you take away the oil they have
to drill the energies and talent and
intelligence of all their people not
just their sand dunes and when you do
that I trust me the veil comes off okay
and everybody gets an opportunity and so
that to me you know is all good news and
that's why the greatest thing we could
do is to wean gradually this part of the
world off of oil we have a New York
Times has a stringer in Iran a really
woman who's a dear friend of mine and
we're walking down the street and tear
on a couple a couple years ago now and
she's just said to me out of the blue
she said you know Tom if only we didn't
have oil we could be just like Japan and
you know she understood exactly what the
problem was you know and so the first
impact would be in that sphere um the
second impact you know it depend again
what kind of regime and what character
is it would it would be a total shock to
every one of those leaders to the Saudi
leaders to the Kuwait ease to the
Egyptians it would be a complete shock
and they would increasingly I think be
under pressure to at least put on a
democratic patina if not some real
democratization yeah see well the
initial reaction would be to tighten up
but over time you know kind of all this
stuff would would would pour out it
could be extremely destabilizing but I
tell you what I feel okay this is a
region that has been on vacation from
globalization and democratization since
the start okay and vacation is soon
going to be over because there is a huge
population explosion happening there
from Morocco to the border of India and
the real price of oil is gradually going
down and you know Saudi Arabia musi
what's happened real income I mean per
capita income there's gone from 27,000
in 1981 to 6,000 today and you feel it
when you're there and you feel sorry for
people there you know I think of a
middle-class Saudi dad okay I call him
soccer dad on steroids okay why think of
a middle-class Saudi dad with six girls
none of whom can drive and he can't
afford a chauffeur okay
now this is a real story I mean friends
who might tell me I got this guy he's a
middle manager he's not a wealthy man
he's got it all girls he can't afford a
driver so he's always leaving work to
take one to their school back to the
ballet lesson the wife got to go to the
shopping center think I loony that is
think of the loss of productivity
there is no redeeming social value I can
think of you know to justify that but
think of what the distortions
creates there's a lot of people like
that there's a lot of middle-class
Saudis okay who are really hurting and
this is all bubbling up you know what
I'm really saying is that part of the
world is heading for an explosion it's
gonna head for an explosion whether we
push democracy or don't push democracy
because there are too many young people
who know about the world who are on the
internet who want other things they want
the opportunities that other people have
not to give up their faith there is
devoted to their faith you know and to
Islam is ever before but they don't want
to live this way and it's gonna blow I
don't know when I don't know how and the
first place it's going to blow is in
Iran yeah all the way back you behind
you thank you
in this room democracy and dialogue okay
answer your question I think I know what
it is right right yeah yeah I I don't
buy that frankly I mean I think that's a
too pessimistic view you know of America
and American democracy and but I will
say the part of your your critique that
I do buy is the fact that basically what
we've been doing all these years is
treating the Middle East Saudi Arabia
countries like that it's really just a
big gas station and we treat them as
just a big gas station all we cared
about was that when we drove up the gas
was there and the price was cheap
we didn't care what was going on out
back we didn't care who was being
repressed we didn't care what women were
being allowed to do we didn't care what
was being taught in the schools
we didn't care what they were saying
even about us we just didn't care we
just cared about the gas and I think
that if there's one long-term shake out
from 9/11 it will be to change that it's
not going to happen maybe with this
administration in 12 months but think of
where they've come you've had the
president now give a couple of speeches
and the vice president I'm just saying
where they've come
I believe me I'm not you know taking
this you know to the bank but for these
guys where they have come in raising
this issue of democracy and reform you
know in religion that's a really
important thing because when it starts
to be said
from the bully pulpit of the president's
the United States it really does echo it
does have an effect and so I think see I
look at this last year I look at 9/11
like Pearl Harbor it's the it's a cliche
but it's true it's the Pearl Harbor of
our generation
and so what I measure myself is that was
December 7th 1941 this were coming up to
December 7th 1941 have we accomplished
in the first year of what could be a
five six or ten year struggle and I
don't think it's been a terrible year
there's so much that needs to be done so
much we haven't done but I see signals
like that of issues that are now being
raised that were never raised before as
a sign of health so yeah
good point
sure sure well let's call for
congressional les that's damn
congressional leaders as well for that
I'd be I'm not trying to excuse them I
was really sort of focused on the
administration because I think there's
nothing like the president and
congressional leaders can call and do
for a lot of things but it doesn't
really replace the president all I know
about leaks is what I read in the
newspaper um the question was um how do
I know the administration has leaked the
war plans and all I know is what I read
in the newspaper quoting Pentagon and
and different officials so I'm just
going by that somebody's leaked them or
somebody's leaked war plans maybe it's
all just a big feint um if it is it's
terrific mm-hmm I'm not belittling
right right right well let me let me
then clarify because just for a
clarification I don't believe the
president the vice president Rumsfeld or
Cheney or Powell leaked this information
although nothing would surprise me
frankly in my experience as a journalist
but I don't believe that but I do
believe that somebody with a senior
enough status to know or think they knew
what was going on that is within the
administration broadly construed seem to
have done it is that good okay
thank you yeah then I'll come back
well you've said well give it back to
the the west bank they had the West Bank
in 1967 and it's insensitive sure um the
question is what would you do right now
if you were the Prime Minister of Israel
given the situation in the neighborhood
and and here I'm going to tell you that
I'm just not sure anymore and I will
tell you why everything right now is so
broken between Israelis and Palestinians
that I'm just not sure where you start
to rebuild anything
I believe Israel's dilemma today is that
it cannot stay in the territories and
remain a Jewish democracy because by by
2020 there's going to be first of all a
majority of Arabs and Muslims between
the Jordan River and the Mediterranean
and then they're just gonna ask for
majority rule okay so I don't believe
Israel can stay there I also believe
Israel cannot leave the territories and
remain a Jewish democracy under the
conditions that exist today and given
what's going on with the Palestinians
that's a real dilemma and my answer for
that dilemma because the only one I can
think of other than just sheer pessimism
and throwing up your hands has been to
call for NATO to take over the West Bank
in Gaza
that's what I wrote you know six months
ago I still believe that that is the
only coherent solution a solution that
will get Israel out but in a way that
would not leave Israel completely
exposed to attacks from those other now
you can sit here and we can both sit
here and think of ten different reasons
why that's a bad idea
and won't work okay but I tell you if
you think the status quo is benign or if
you think the status quo isn't maybe a
lot more dangerous than that I would be
very happy to have that discussion with
you but I'm going to tell you this it's
a really hard question I don't have the
answers anymore and if you notice I
can't even write about it anymore
because you know I I covered the Middle
East in war for a lot of years and then
I covered it in peace you know for a lot
of years but a Middle East in war after
piece like we've just had places I've
never been before because what happens
in when you have war after piece and
this is what I screamed from the
rooftops at the Palestinians at the
start of this Intifada don't do this
because you will shatter every bit of
confidence that has been built up over
ten years and as a result I gotta just
tell you honestly I wish I could give
you a magic cure I'm out of bullets the
the vaz has been shattered it's all over
the floor and I really just don't know
what to do I only know what needs to be
done that Israel for its own safety and
integrity needs to disengage from those
areas as quickly and safely as it can
but I can't tell you I have the answer
oh no you don't you get it okay so let
me explain it to you okay I'm not
looking for the Arab world to have
therapy okay and suddenly come to a
resolution that they're gonna love
Israel that's not gonna happen okay and
if you want to wait for that you can
wait forever and when you wait forever
you're gonna wake up one morning and
find that there is an Arab majority
between the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean I'm talking about how
Israel can reconfigure its lines to have
a safer more Jewish more democratic
state I don't really know I'm not
looking for the other side to say I'm
sorry you wait for that you wait forever
one more right there just take a couple
more and yeah go ahead Islamic clerics
at the most anti modernist among them to
be natural allies of autocratic regimes
get you also stated that they have a
great need to deport them and I'm
certain are the most radical among them
I'm talking about pardon me she extolled
the virtues of democracy and then in one
sentence had no trouble mentioning that
we absolutely must throw these people in
prison there to address yeah
so where's where's the Alliance and
where's the right um the question is you
know why on the one hand do you say that
they need to throw these bad radical
leaders Muslim clerics out or that they
feel they need to throw them out and at
the same time saying what oh they cut a
deal right well that's very simple
because right yeah right right yeah
there's a very simple question to their
official clerics and their unofficial
clerics the guys they're throwing in
jail okay are not guys on the state
payroll these are independent you know
preachers teachers organizers and
radicals there is a state religious
structure that is very much in
partnership with the government there
are people outside that yeah I've talked
about people outside the structure are
the ones that have been expelled jailed
and alike so there's there's there's a
difference between the two yeah a young
person
if I'm if I'm not mistaken I believe the
second-greatest the country that
contributed the second greatest number
of hijackers the September 11th was
Egypt that country it seems his
experiment and to an extent with
democratization do you see that
significant and what do you think um the
second the question was um was whispered
that um the second largest number of
hijackers beyond the Saudis were
Egyptians and yet Egypt has experimented
with democratization so what do you say
to that is that a fair if Egypt has
experimented with democratization I've
missed that experiment because the last
thing I saw with Egypt and
democratization was President Mubarak is
throwing in jail and sentencing to seven
years in jail a 63 year old Egyptian
American for one crime only and that was
promoting democratization so I'm afraid
I won't to buy that connection just a
couple more and I think it's a really
serious question and the question is you
know how do you feel when European
leaders basically come out and say we
don't have anything to do with your war
with Saddam Hussein was the Porsche
against Osama bin Laden but not in in
that war I have a lot of different
reactions I think when Jared Schroeder
says that he says it as a friend and he
says it as a pro-american and therefore
I take it really seriously
if it were to come from you know there
are other people out there in Europe
elsewhere in the world whom I think
really are into a kind of knee-jerk anti
Americanism and it doesn't matter
whether there's Clinton or Bush or
Saddam or Osama they really don't care
if we want it it's wrong okay and I
think we also have to disaggregate and
be attentive to the difference between
the two
but you know I've kind of been over the
view that um there are only three
opposition figures in this country today
and none of them are in the Democratic
Party in this country yeah that is
they're only three people that really
sort of rattle the Bush administration
and none of them are Democrats one is
Colin Powell one is Tony Blair and the
third is john mccain okay
Tony Blair the Prime Minister of England
yeah that is I think only those three
guys and where they stand
Blair McCain and Powell are the real
kind of opposition that Bush cares about
because if any of the three of them
really bailed out on this it would have
a resonance around the world and with
the wider public in a way with all due
respect you know that no leader of the
Democratic Party today unfortunately
what happened and so I've always said
you know there's three members of the
opposition these three guys so pay
attention to what they have to say and I
think if you listen to all of them what
they've said I think going back to your
question is that while they lean you
know in favor of the moral and strategic
arguments here they have a lot of
reservations of how this is done and how
it's done right and I would put Schroder
you know in that same camp and I think
for all these reasons Bush is gonna have
to take very seriously how we go about
this war how we sell it and produce
arguments that are convincing first and
foremost to the American people you know
and and then we'll worry about the
others but I think they're a long way
from doing that yet yeah
I've always understood that the Saudis
and all of the right
Regulation
what is that what would be the financial
consequences of a deteriorating
relationship between the United States
and Saudi Arabia given the heavy Saudi
investment in this country I'm not an
expert in the subject I and I don't know
the figures and so I don't want to wing
it what I've read in the paper reports
of withdrawals of anywhere from two
hundred million dollars to you know five
hundred million dollars in the wake of
the lawsuit brought against Saudi Arabia
and the bit at the Pentagon you know in
a what is our you know in a multi
trillion dollar economy I don't think
it's going to be decisive in any way
frankly but beyond that I don't know
it's a legitimate question I don't know
yeah
oh no no don't get me wrong I don't
think this could happen suddenly at all
I mean the question was really um you
know can you know since it took
Christianity all this time to do this
why do I think Islam can suddenly evolve
a 3.0 point one I don't think it can
happen suddenly at all
I just think today is the first day of
the rest of our lives and we got to
start now so hopefully in 50 years or 75
years or or maybe I don't know but all I
know is if you don't if you don't take
the first step you know somebody had to
yeah okay absolutely no I think it's a
legitimate question but this is
unfortunately not like doing a new
version of Microsoft Word I would say
one more question yeah transient
right absolutely we've tried to do this
these have impact in terms of more than
just whether Islam is going to get to
this stage each of these religions
towards I hate to use the word
fundamental but
well let me just try to give to your
question by by saying it's a legitimate
point that the it's a really a question
about um the struggle with in religions
all religions where you have
fundamentalist trends and non
fundamentalist trends and that's that is
um that is absolutely true and and
that's struggle going back to the young
lady's question back there
it's still going on today within
Christianity and Judaism okay
very absolutely you got no question
right yeah absolutely but but there is
the dominant trend and there is a and
there is a less dominant trend in in
both I would argue any of if they're
equal trends I would settle for that
within Islam I would settle for a real
struggle over that issue within Islam in
an equal way from outside right and
that's my point
no you're absolutely right and I agree
with you in my own travels I have come
up with so many to serve so many you
know Muslim friends around their world
who have talked to me about this issue
but the fact that it has to happen
outside and not inside is the whole
problem because only when you have an
inside and then goes outside are you
really gonna have a change and so yeah
and that's where democracy is important
I got to stop because I've got I really
want to sign books if I can and I want
to thank you very much
Thomas Friedman is author of longitudes
and attitudes published by fair Straus
and Giroux visit SFG books comm for more
information